[NO SPEECH]
SEAN ROBINSON: Other
challenges include learning
how to do data analysis.
You perform an
experiment in such a way
that it hopefully gives you
data that is worth analyzing.
And data analysis
begins with that.
Did you even perform the
experiment in a good way?
But then there's just
technicalities of I
have a table of numbers
that my apparatus gave me,
how do I analyze that?
I have to get it into
a piece of software.
I have to tell that
software, make me a plot.
Compute an average.
Just basic mechanical things.
We don't care what
programming language they use.
Whatever they use, we
promise to help them out
with the basics of it.
But really, some
of the basic tasks
they're doing in whatever
programming language
it is, they're usually not
very sophisticated tasks
on the scale of
computer programming.
They're usually
very simple things.
But if you don't
know how to do it,
they're very daunting tasks.
We want students in this class
to struggle with the material.
To really work at the things
that are useful to learning.
We don't want them to struggle
with things that are just,
my computer won't
compile my paper.
We don't want to
struggle with things that
are not useful to learning.
So again, we have a long
series of small tasks
that gets people up to speed
with some instructor help.
Gets them up to speed quickly
on these multiple small tasks.
So that they are
spending their time
learning in an efficient
way, and not just spinning
their wheels.
And just getting frustrated and
learning to hate the subject,
instead of love the
subject like we do.